لم تذهب هتافاتهم سدا المحتجون في ايران
حقق انتصارا نوعيا وذلك بعد قرابه اربعه
اشهر من التظاهرات المستمره شرطه الاخلاق
ليس لها علاقه بالقضاء والغاها من انشاها
اعلان هو التراجع الاول من النظام
للمحتجين الذين ورغم مقتل المئات منهم
حافظوا على زخم الاحتجاجات وتوسعها من
محافظه اخرى المدعي العام الايراني المح
ايضا الى ان البرلمان والسلطه القضائيه
يعملان على مراجعه قانون الحجاب متوقعا ان
تظهر نتائج هذه المراجعه خلال اسبوعين على
الاكثر
النظام المحب دوره الى مزيد من التنازلات
في محاوله الاحتواء غضب الشارع
تنازلات قد تصل الى حد ادخال تعديلات على
الدستورنا له مواد ثابته وغير قابله تغيير
جمهوريه النظام واسلامته ومبدا الاستقلال
والحريه والحقوق والحريات التي يصرح بها
الدستور اساليب واليات لتطبيق القانون
ولكن يمكن دراستها
تصريحات حاره الشارع الغاضب في تفسيرها
بين من اعتبرها اذعانا للضغوط الداخليه
والخارجيه ومن عدها تكتيكا مؤقتا يهدف
لمنح قوى الامن وقتا كافيا للقضاء على
التظاهرات
بل ان تلميح رئيس بامكانيه تعديل الدستور
قد لا يجدوا طريقه للتنفيذ في الواقع
لاسباب مختلفه
فالدستور الايراني يمنح المرشد الاعلى
صلاحيات مطلقه تمكنه من الغاء اي قرار في
البلاد والمرشد الاعلى علي الخامنائي يعد
القائد الاعلى للقوات الايرانيه اي انه
يتفرد بالقوه المطلقه
ورغم هذا يحتفل محتاجون بقرار الغاء شرطه
الاخلاق واعاده النظر في قانون الحجاب
فالقرارات ولو كانت شكليه الا انها تعني
ان النظام مستعد لتقديم المزيد في حال
استمرار التظاهرات